[Music]
can the Megalodon from the Me 2 defeat
Lizzy from Rampage or can the group of
three of them take down the mutated
crocodile let's dive into the
possibilities and imagine scenarios on
such a battle at the same time let's
make a short comparison between these
creatures so let's get to it firstly
let's take a look at the origins of the
Megalodon and Lizzy from Rampage so
Lizzy is the main antagonist of the
movie Rampage she is a mutated crocodile
a monster and is usually depicted as one
of three main creatures the other two
being George the giant gorilla and Ralph
the giant flying wolf she is a mutated
crocodile resulting from a crashed
capsule containing anes experimental
pathogen crashing into the evades in
Florida the pathogen inside the capsule
was swallowed by a crocodile which in a
couple of days Alters its genetic makeup
turning the Croc into a massive creature
called Lizzy the Megalodon on the other
hand is one of three or many shars in
the species from the movie and the novel
franchise called the Meg these animals
survive extinction by thriving within a
hidden ecosystem inside the Mariana's
Trench in the Pacific Ocean in the books
the place is called the balasa sea the
sharks are huge bigger than real life
extinct megalodons and are far more
ruthless so while the shock is a natural
species Lizzy on the other hand is a
mutated animal
so now let's dive into the size
comparison of these two monsters anyway
after watching the movie twice to make
two of the trench we found out the sizes
of the five megalodons that have made
their appearances in two flaks the first
movie and the sequel the size ranges
from the smallest which is the first to
be seen in the first movie which is
around 15 M or 50 ft long then the
smallest from the second movie is around
60 ft or 18 M and the biggest of the
first film along with the middle one
from the sequel would be around 20 24 M
or 80 ft and yeah the biggest that was
described in the me to of the trench was
around 120 ft or 37 M then there's also
the one from the Prelude from 65 million
years in the past devouring an adult
T-Rex like it was nothing that was
around 180 ft or 55 M easily now as for
the monster Croc called Lizzy she was a
small crocodile at first but then after
the mutagen override her DNA and mutated
her she grew to be around 200 ft or 61 m
long far bigger than any Megalodon so
let's take a look at the durability and
power of the Megalodon shock this shock
because it lives deep underwater is
adapted to the immense pressures and
inhospitable conditions of the trench
they were large and hence very
physically powerful capable of
overturning boats and Ys with ease their
skin is highly resilient due to their
nature but can still be punctured by
sharp objects and explosions the first
me was killed by a poison shot weak
where the second one was severely
wounded by a damaged submersible and
then killed by a stab right through the
eye into the brain that's from the first
movie so as for the sequel one of the
mechs was killed by an explosive weapon
that was improvised by the human
characters while the second one was
killed by a sharp metal impaling it from
the mouth into its brain so even though
they were Beast among bees in the ocean
killing a kraken in one instance and
swallowing an entire T-Rex hole and also
establishing dominance over every other
the creature in the trench they can
still be impaled stabbed and killed by
small explosions which shows that they
are far from being
Invincible now let's take a look at the
durability and power of Lizzy upon
infection by the pathogen her size
magnifies to gargantuan proportions
endowing her with unmatch physical
strength Lizzy effortlessly lifts and
propels military vehicles around and
easily obliterates structures her
colossal Jaws bows and astonishing
capacity to shatter
helicopters moreover her exceptional
durability stems from her heavily
armored height capable of withstanding
bullets missiles and even attacks from
her other fellow monsters lizz's
powerfulness extends underwat thanks to
the fish-like guills which allow her to
stay underwater indefinitely and to
breathe just like fish do Lizzie also
has fought against two other monsters
killing the wolf and dominating the
battle against Josh the giant gorilla
Josh couldn't impale her with her own
damage does the missiles from the Apache
helicopter couldn't bring it down and it
took being impaled through the eye into
the brain for it to actually die this
shows the extreme resilience of the
giant
croc so battle while their exact
capabilities and behavior are subject to
interpretation they are generally
considered to be Apex Monsters of their
own franchises but a single Megalodon
even if it was the biggest specimen the
one from 65 million years ago would
still be smaller than Lizzy and as you
know in nature and in fights size thus
matter
honestly in a one-on-one fight the Shar
would be ripped to pieces with Lizzy not
even being wounded in any way this would
be a battle underwater where the Shar
might have an advantage in speed but
that's all it has it could swim away but
as for its battle prowers if it was to
go one-on one a single Mech no that's
next to Impossible Lizzy's great reflect
speed under water would catch the fish
before it even makes a single bite not
to mention how much of an effect the
bite would have and now what about the
group of men eggs can a pack of these
giant shars defeat the mutant crocodile
well Lizzy is outnumbered here and the
shars do have a bite force more powerful
than any other living creature but could
a bite from a shock overcome the armored
skin that even Hellfire missiles from an
Apache helicopter could not researchers
have estimated that the Megalodon had a
bite force between 100,000 and 180,000
Newtons and for the bigger fictional
Megs in the movie it could be as high as
300,000 Newtons and they have been seen
ripping of metal structures deep within
a trench so if the skin of Lizzy is
within their bite limits they could
potentially rip the Croc to shreds but
if a Hellfire missile that is usually
used to destroy tanks and bunkers could
not affect the Rampage monster how could
teeth make a difference and that's the
answer no Lizzy rules the tail Club as
well as the claws and the flexible body
would also give the Croc the ability to
counteract to Counterattack to repel and
to triple kill the all in a short amount
of time in fact so that's the result
between a pack of Megs fighting Lizzy
from Rampage who would win the mutant
crocodile anyway we have come to the end
of the video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe to support us and
push us through in the YouTube algorithm
but most of all smash the Bell icon for
regular updates and new videos here on
this channel take care
fam